FOX NEWS, NOW PROJECTING WINS
FOR JOE BIDEN IN FLORIDA AND
ILLINOIS.
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THAT.
BUT WE START TONIGHT WITH AN
IMPORTANT MESSAGE FROM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SO, IT’S 15 DAYS FROM
YESTERDAY.
WE’LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS AFTER
THAT.
IF WE DO THIS RIGHT, OUR COUNTRY
AND THE WORLD, FRANKLY, BUT OUR
COUNTRY CAN BE ROLLING AGAIN
PRETTY QUICKLY.
WE HAVE TO FIGHT THAT INVISIBLE
ENEMY THAT IS I GUESS UNKNOWN,
BUT WE ARE GETTING TO KNOW IT A
LOT BETTER.
>> Sean: INVISIBLE ENEMY.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
AS WE SPEAK, THE ENTIRE WORLD IS
IN A FIGHT AGAINST THAT ENEMY.
NOW, MAJOR FINANCIAL HELP IS ON
THE WAY.
THE WHITE HOUSE, ACTIVELY
WORKING ON AN AGGRESSIVE ALMOST
TRILLION DOLLAR STIMULUS PACKAGE
INCLUDING PAYROLL TAX CUTS,
MONEY FOR SMALL BUSINESSES,
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE TO MAJOR
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THIS VIRUS.
THAT WOULD MEAN, YEAH, THE
AIRLINE INDUSTRY, CRUISE
INDUSTRY, TREASURY SECRETARY
SAID THAT THE PRESIDENT WANTS
AMERICANS TO RECEIVE CHECKS
WITHIN TWO WEEKS.
LOOK, WE ARE AMERICANS.
WE ARE GOING TO HELP OUT OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS.
THIS COUNTRY REBUILD EUROPE
AFTER WORLD WAR II CALL.
WE SAVED AN ENTIRE WORLD
NUMEROUS TIMES FROM EVIL AND
TYRANNY.
WE DID IT AGAIN AND AGAIN.
WE PAID THAT PRICE.
WE MUST HELP OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS LIKE POST-9/11.
INDUSTRIES, DIRECTLY IMPACTED.
THEY WILL RIGHTLY GET THE HELP
THEY DESERVE.
AMERICAN WORKERS, THEY’VE GOT TO
GET THE HELP THEY DESERVE.
WE HELP COUNTRIES EVERY DAY AND
NIGHT AND EVERY SINGLE TIME.
WE HELP THE WORLD.
SMALL BUSINESS, THEY’VE GOT TO
GET THE HELP THEY DESERVE AND
NEED, AND HOPEFULLY SOMETHING
NONPARTISAN.
I HAVE A HUGE CAVEAT ON THIS.
ALL OF YOU SWAMP CREATURES, PAY
ATTENTION.
WE WILL FIND THE MONEY.
THAT’S WHO WE ARE.
BUT, WASHINGTON, ALL OF YOU,
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS, STOP
WITH THE MISUSE OF OUR TAX
DOLLARS.
YOU REMEMBER CONGRESS, THIS IS
NOT ABOUT YOUR SPECIAL INTEREST
PROJECT.
THIS MONEY, EVERY PENNY OF THIS
MONEY NEEDS TO GO TO AMERICAN
WORKERS AND AMERICAN BUSINESSES
DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY THE VIRUS.
THAT’S IT.
THAT’S WHAT THIS BILL SHOULD BE.
NOTHING MORE, NOTHING LESS.
IT’S GOT TO BE MANAGED WISELY,
SO PEOPLE WHO NEED THE
ASSISTANCE GET THE ASSISTANCE
AND GET IT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
NOT POWER-HUNGRY POLITICIANS WHO
BUILD THEIR POWER BASE BY
CREATING DEPENDENCY THAT WANT TO
SPEND IT ON ISSUES THAT HAVE
NOTHING CORONAVIRUS-RELATED.
THIS IS A CRUCIAL MOMENT,
BECAUSE EVEN NOW THE U.S.
MILITARY IS CONFRONTING THE
CORONAVIRUS.
BREAKING TONIGHT, THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE, THEY ARE NOW
DEPLOYING 5,000,095 MASKS TO
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
NATIONWIDE.
THAT’S GREAT NEWS.
WHY?
WELL, WE GOT TO PROTECT
HEALTH CARE WORKERS THAT THROW
THEMSELVES IN FRONT OF THIS
VIRUS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THEY’VE GOT TO BE PROTECTED.
THAT A PART OF DEFENSE IS ALSO
RELATION AN ADDITIONAL 2,000
VENTILATORS IN CASE CIVILIANS
NEED THEM IN PARTIAL DOMINIC
PREPARATION.
THEY ARE NOW BEING PREPARED FOR
POSSIBLE DEPLOYMENT TO HELP
OVERCROWDING IN HOSPITALS.
PLUS, THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
IS OPENING 14 NEW CORONAVIRUS
CERTIFIED TESTING LABS.
THE NATIONAL GUARD NOW ASSIST IN
STATES WITH LOGISTICS AND
MEDICAL SUPPORT.
ALL HANDS ON DECK SITUATION
PAIRED BY THE WAY, STATES,
GOVERNORS, MUNICIPALITIES,
YOU’VE GOT TO DO YOUR JOB TOO.
THANKS TO SOME VERY DECISIVE
EARLY ACTION BY THE PRESIDENT,
WE ARE NOW IN A POSITION TO BEAT
THIS DISEASE, MITIGATE THE
IMPACT.
EVERY DAY, WE NOW SEE HOW
CRITICAL THIS WAS AT A CRITICAL
TIME.
AND VERY SUCCESSFUL.
SLOWING THE SPREAD OF THAT
DISEASE.
AND NOW, EUROPEAN UNION IS
REPLICATING THE BAND WITHIN
THEIR OWN BORDERS.
IT’S A LITTLE LATE FOR THEM.
THE FIRST CASE IN THIS COUNTRY
WAS JANUARY 21ST.
THE FIRST KNOWN CASE PAIR THE
TRAVEL BAN WAS PUT IN PLACE TEN
DAYS LATER ON JANUARY 31ST.
NOBODY HAS EVER ACTED THAT
QUICKLY TO STOP THE SPREAD OF
THE PANDEMIC.
CAN ANYONE FIND ONE GOOD THING
TO SAY ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP?
WE WILL GET TO THAT LATER.
ON THE VERY SAME DAY, OH,
QUID PRO QUO DR. JOE SAID IT WAS
FEARMONGERING AND XENOPHOBIC AND
HYSTERICAL.
THAT ONE DECISION, THAT TRAVEL
BAN PREVENTED THIS PANDEMIC FROM
BEING EXPONENTIALLY WORSE,
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS WOULD HAVE CONTRACTED
THIS DISEASE AND IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN DRAMATICALLY MORE DIFFICULT
IS ATTAIN AND MITIGATE.
IT IS RESULTING IN EXPEDITED
TESTING FOR AMERICANS.
THEY NOW HAVE DRIVE THROUGH
TESTING CENTERS.
THAT’S A GOOD THINKER THE LAST
PLACE YOU REALLY WANT TO BE AS A
HOSPITAL.
WE NEED BEDS FOR PEOPLE WHO
REALLY NEED IT.
NUMBER ONE, NUMBER TWO, IT’S A
PETRI DISH.
YOU DON’T WANT TO BE THERE.
MEDICAL RESEARCHERS ARE NOW
RAPIDLY DEVELOPING NOT ONLY
TREATMENTS, BUT HOPEFULLY A
VACCINE.
THIS UNPRECEDENTED COOPERATION
BETWEEN THE GOVERNMENT, PRIVATE
INDUSTRY, THIS WILL NOT FOREVER
CHANGE THE WAY THIS COUNTRY AND
THE WORLD WILL DEAL WITH FUTURE
PANDEMICS AND CRISES JUST LIKE
THE TRAVEL BAN.
UNFORTUNATELY, BAD NEWS TO
REPORT.
WHY THEY ARE DOING THIS?
I DON’T KNOW.
THEY ARE PLACING AN INDEFINITE
PAWS ON ARRESTS FOR CERTAIN
NONVIOLENT CRIMES.
CRIMES ARE STILL HAD A WARRANT
SERVED FOR A LATER DATE.
THIS IS A REALLY BAD IDEA THAT
WILL LICENSE PEOPLE TO COMMIT
CRIMES AND SOMETIMES MAJOR CASES
CASES.
THEY MUST CONTINUE TO ENFORCE
THE LAW, ESPECIALLY IN TIMES OF
UNCERTAINTY OR YOU WILL HAVE
MORE LAWBREAKING.
THEY WILL SAY GO AHEAD, YOU ARE
FINE.
THAT’S NOT GOOD FOR THE PEOPLE
OF PHILADELPHIA.
WE’LL KEEP YOU POSTED.
ALSO, LET’S GET TO SOME
IMPORTANT FACTS AND INFORMATION
AGAIN WITHOUT FEAR.
TONIGHT, AS EXPECTED, THE NUMBER
OF CONFIRMED CORONAVIRUS CASES
IS RISING.
THERE ARE NO MORE THAN 6,000
CONFIRMED CASES IN THE
UNITED STATES PAIRED WE’VE BEEN
TELLING YOU THIS IS HAPPENING.
SADLY NOW OVER 100 DEAD THIS IN.
THE NUMBER WILL LIKELY ARISE
SEEMINGLY AND DRAMATICALLY IN
THE NEXT DAYS AND WEEKS.
THE HOPE IS THAT IF WE FOLLOW
THE PRESIDENT, VICE PRESIDENT
FOR HIS 15 DAY RECOMMENDATION,
WE WILL MITIGATE THE SPREAD OF
THIS VIRUS.
SO, THAT’S WHY IT’S IMPORTANT.
LISTEN UP.
IT’S MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER TO
HEED THE GUIDANCE OF THIS
TASK FORCE AND THE PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE CALLING ON ALL OF US TO
DO THIS FOR THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND SECURITY, ESPECIALLY
FOR OLDER AMERICANS.
THOSE WITH COMPROMISED IMMUNE
SYSTEMS, UNDERLYING HEALTH
CONDITIONS.
TAKE THE PRECAUTIONS OF THE NEXT
COUPLE OF WEEKS.
DO IT WHY?
BECAUSE WE LOVE OUR
GRANDMOTHERS, OUR GRANDFATHERS
COME OUR OLDER MOMS AND DADS.
THEY ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE.
THEY ARE THE MOST AT RISK.
IF YOU FEEL SICK, STAY HOME.
IF THE KIDS FEEL SICK, KEEP THEM
AT HOME.
ANYONE IN YOUR HOUSE TESTING
POSITIVE FOR THE CORONAVIRUS,
KEEP THE ENTIRE HOUSEHOLD AT
HOME.
IF YOU ARE AN ELDERLY PERSON OR
SOMEONE WITH THESE UNDERLYING
MEDICAL CONDITIONS OR YOU HAVE
AN AUTOIMMUNE DISEASE, YOU NEED
TO STAY AWAY FROM OTHER PEOPLE
ON YOUR OWN.
IF POSSIBLE, WORK FROM HOME.
AVOID DISCRETIONARY TRAVEL.
AVOID SOCIAL GATHERINGS.
AVOID NURSING HOMES.
AVOID LARGE GROUP SETTINGS.
IN OTHER WORDS, FOR THE NEXT TWO
WEEKS, STAY AT HOME.
WE HOPE YOU WILL STAY WITH US
HERE AT FOX NEWS.
BUT, WE ARE TRYING TO GET YOU
THE INFORMATION THAT WILL KEEP
YOUR FAMILY SAFE.
BUT, BY SIMPLY DOING NOTHING, WE
CAN ALL SAVE LIVES.
WE CAN FLATTEN THE CURVE OF THE
DISEASE AND GET BACK TO NORMAL.
WE WILL EVENTUALLY.
THE GREAT WINSTON CHURCHILL, IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE BOMBING OF
BRITAIN, EVERY SINGLE DAY, HE
WALKED AMONG THE PEOPLE OF
GREAT BRITAIN.
BLOOD, TOIL, TEAR, AND SWEAT.
THAT WAS THE GOAL.
WE WILL BE VICTORIOUS HERE.
HE REQUIRES LITTLE MORE THAN
SOCIAL DISTANCING FOR THE
MAJORITY OF OUR POPULATION.
WE CAN ALL DO OUR PART, LIKE I
SAID IN AN ALL HANDS ON DECK
SITUATION.
FOR MANY, THE VAST MAJORITY, NO.
IF YOU ARE YOUNG, HEALTHY, YOU
DON’T HAVE A COMPROMISED IMMUNE
SYSTEM, IF YOU HAVE CONTRACTED
THE VIRUS, YOU MAY HAVE NO
SYMPTOMS.
IT IS PASSING IT ON TO THOSE
PEOPLE THAT WOULD BE AT RISK.
THIS COUNTRY WILL BE FINE IN THE
END.
WE HAVE THE BEST DOCTORS,
HOSPITALS, SCIENTISTS, MEDICAL
RESEARCHERS, THE GREATEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD, AND WE
HAVE AN ABUNDANCE OF FOOD, AN
ABUNDANCE OF NATURAL RESOURCES,
A ROBUST, HARDWORKING,
INTELLIGENT POPULATION.
THEY ARE FILLING THOSE --
DON’T RUN IN FOR TOILET PAPER AN
EXTRA PAPER TOWELS.
I DON’T GET IT.
THEY’RE GOING TO BE FILLING THE
SHELVES EVERYWHERE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
THAT IS ALSO IN THE WORKS
TONIGHT.
WE WILL PULL TOGETHER.
WE WILL DEFEAT THIS INVISIBLE
ENEMY.
LAWMAKERS IN WASHINGTON, YOU
NEED TO PUT ASIDE THE B.S.
POLITICS.
THESE AMERICANS NEED HELP.
DON’T WASTE OUR MONEY.
DON’T WASTE IT.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO OUR
HARDWORKING AMERICANS.
GIVE IT TO THE PEOPLE THAT
DESERVE IT AND ONLY THE PEOPLE
THAT DESERVE IT IN THE RIGHT
WAY.
SET THE ECONOMY UP FOR --
BEFORE WE GET TO OUR GUEST, I
HAVE MORE IMPORTANT MESSAGE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
THE DICTATORSHIP OF CHINA IS --
THIS IS WHERE THE PANDEMIC
STARTED.
I’M NOT SAYING THEY ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE PANDEMIC.
THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR BEING
IRRESPONSIBLE TRYING TO HIDE IT,
MISINFORMING THE REST OF THE
WORLD RATHER THAN INVITING THE
WORLD TO OFFER THEIR HELP AND
ASSISTANCE TO THEM.
NOW, DURING THAT CRITICAL, THOSE
CRITICAL EARLY STAGES, CHINA’S
SO-CALLED LEADERS, THEY TRIED TO
COVER EVERYTHING UP AND INSTEAD
ALERTING THE COMMUNITY.
MANY, THEMSELVES, NOT
CONTRACTING THE VIRUS APPEARED
SOME HAVE EVEN DIED.
CHINA’S GOVERNMENT SPREADING
FAKE INFORMATION, PROPAGANDA,
AND LIES.
THEY ARE FALSELY EVEN BLAMING
THE U.S. MILITARY FOR THE
DISEASE.
I WAS GLAD THE PRESIDENT PUSHED
BACK HARD AGAINST THEM FOR THAT.
THAT WAS PART OF THEIR MASSIVE
GOVERNMENT.
YOU ALL SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
YOURSELVES AND CHINA, BECAUSE
IT’S YOUR RECKLESS ACTIONS THAT
HAVE LED TO THOUSANDS OF DADS,
NOT ONLY IN YOUR OWN COUNTRY BUT
AROUND THE WORLD
WE HAVE WOULD HAVE DELL MIGHT GL
HELP TOO.
MILLIONS MORE ARE NOW SUFFERING
BECAUSE OF YOUR ROLE
DICTATORSHIP AND YOUR LACK OF A
CON ABILITY.
YOU ULTIMATELY NEED TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ALL OF THAT.